OK.
We've had a bit of a short break from hatriot
mail due to breaking news, but I do want to
get back to it.
What is hatriot mail?
This is hatriot mail between a renowned infectious
disease expert and the guy who ran a fake
university and bankrupted the casino.
I'm going to have to go with the casino guy
tricked me, written by patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because freedom
got to love the new relevant Corona virus
introductions.
Here is a very timely hatriot mail related
to the race to one million YouTube subscribers.
Take a listen.
I'm not a fan of David Cuckold Pacman do in
cells.
Right.
Your headlines now.
Shame on you, Pacman.
What's terrifying is that this guy actually
has an audience.
Imagine if he got to one million subscribers,
you two would be ended.
Pakman cooking.
What a joke.
Does Prak man even know how to fry an egg?
This is a very real risk.
I like how, you know, if Pacman if Pacman
gets to one million subscribers, I don't know.
Things could get really bad.
Well, it seems to be more a matter of when,
not if.
My goal is to get to a million YouTube subscribers
before Election Day.
This really would be a major accomplishment.
What I was thinking back to when we started
the channel and it took us like five years
to get our first hundred thousand subscribers.
We are trying to get our last hundred thousand
will hopefully not the last ever, but the
most recent hundred thousand nine hundred
to a million.
We're trying to do it in just about three
and a half months.
And it would be a record.
And we've already gone from 900000 to nine
hundred and seventeen thousand.
And my prediction is there are going to be
many, many hatriot, very, very upset sometime
between, I don't know, Election Day and the
end of the year.
Oh, between Election Day and Christmas, let's
say when we roll over into the seven digits
for our YouTube subscriber count, fight hatriot
TISM with something that costs nothing.
Just make sure you subscribe to the YouTube
channel, YouTube dot com slash The David Pakman
Show show and I will have updates for you
right now.
We are projected to reach a million on December,
a twenty third.